por primera vez desde que fuera
internado en alemania tras haber sido
envenenado con el agente nervioso
novillo el líder opositor ruso alexéi
navalni se mostró públicamente en una
fotografía publicada en la red social
instagram en la que asegura que ya
comenzó a respirar por sus propios
medios ampliaremos esta información con
nuestro corresponsal en berlín
emiratos árabes unidos bahrein e israel-
firmarán hoy el histórico acuerdo para
normalizar sus relaciones en una
ceremonia en la casa blanca a menos de
dos meses de las elecciones
presidenciales estadounidenses el pacto
representa una victoria diplomática para
donald trump
y el cambio climático se mete de lleno
en la campaña presidencial de eeuu
durante su visita al estado de
california donald trump desestimó al
calentamiento global como causa de los
incendios que han devastado la costa
oeste del país mientras que su rival
demócrata joe biden calificó a trump
como un pirómano climático
muy buenos días saludamos a toda la
audiencia de france 24 en español
muchísimas gracias por acompañarnos su
santiago ariztía y comenzamos esta
emisión de noticias en alemania y es que
por primera vez desde que fuera
internado en este país luego de haber
sido envenenado con el agente nervioso
no vi shock el líder opositor ruso
alexéi navalni se mostró públicamente y
lo hizo en una fotografía publicada en
la red social instagram en esta imagen
puede verse a navalny rodeado de su
familia y un mensaje en el que asegura
que ahora puede respirar por sus propios
medios el caso recordemos despertó la
polémica internacional y el gobierno
ruso se encuentra en el centro de las
miradas acusado de estar detrás de este
ataque vamos a ampliar ya mismo esta
información con tomás sparrow
corresponsal de france 24 en berlín
alemania
hola tomadas contanos que se sabe del
estado actual de salud de naval ni y
también de sus intenciones de volver a
rusia en cuanto se recupere
el mensaje de navalny en la red social
instagram corrobora lo que ya había
dicho ayer el hospital charité aquí en
berlín donde está naval y desde hace
unas semanas el hospital había indicado
que naval ni puede ya respirar por su
propia cuenta es decir que fue retirado
de la respiración artificial que su
estado de salud continúa mejorando y que
puede desplazarse pocos metros de su
cama por periodos específicos
aún por supuesto lo que no está claro es
si hay algún impacto a largo plazo luego
del entrenamiento confirmado por las
autoridades alemanas las autoridades
alemanas por cierto también pidieron a
otros dos países de la unión europea
suecia y a francia que realizara sus
propias investigaciones que también
corroboraron el entrenamiento con el
agente nervioso no que tomamos
otra pregunta que surge no es qué
implicación podría tener esta mejoría de
naval ni en lo que son las
investigaciones por presunto
envenenamiento y también para las sean
muy tensas no relaciones entre rusia y
la unión europea
una implicación muy concreta en términos
de seguridad para las autoridades
alemanas que ahora no solamente tienen
que preocupar a preocuparse de la
mejoría de salud de nava ni sino también
de su seguridad a medida que su
condición mejora y puede recibir más
visitas y es muy cierto lo que ustedes
dicen que las relaciones ya muy tensas
entre rusia y alemán y no solamente
entre los dos países no también entre
rusia y la unión europea pues hay
versiones encontradas sobre exactamente
qué fue lo que le pasó a naval y en
cuanto al caso alemán a la posición
alemana alemania está esperando que
rusia dé más información sobre su
versión y ayude con las investigaciones
también las posibilidades de una
reacción que vaya más allá de las
palabras que hayan indicado los
políticos alemanes van en en una
posibilidad de sanciones aunque también
aquí hay presión para que alemania te va
a con una medida más grande en cuanto al
gasoducto nord stream 2 que es muy
importante entre los dos países
muchísimas gracias tomadas por este
completísimo reporte desde berlín
alemania en otras noticias emiratos
árabes unidos e israel' firmarán este
mismo martes
para normalizar sus relaciones en una
ceremonia que se celebrará en la casa
blanca y con presencia de las
autoridades de bahréin que se sumaron
recientemente a los esfuerzos de paz en
la región la firma de este pacto podría
representar una victoria diplomática
para donald trump a menos de dos meses
de las elecciones presidenciales en el
país pero que significan realmente los
documentos firmados para medio oriente
les explicamos esto en el siguiente
informe
se llaman los acuerdos de abraham un
hombre que hace referencia al patriarca
que comparten el judaísmo el islam y el
cristianismo el acuerdo entre israel y
emiratos árabes unidos para normalizar
las relaciones negociado por eeuu ha
sido calificado de un avance histórico
por los líderes estadounidenses e
israelíes
acordaron finalizar un histórico acuerdo
de paz todos dijeron que esto sería
imposible en base a los griegos que este
es el mayor avance hacia la paz en el
mundo árabe en los últimos 26 años
robadas por destrucción este hecho ha
dividido la opinión internacional
algunos la elogian por promover la paz y
otros la califican de campaña electoral
para donald trump y benjamín netanyahu
quienes han estado buscando una victoria
política exterior
muchos palestinos creen que el acuerdo
los margina ellos confían en los países
árabes para que los ayuden a resistir la
ocupación israelí así que ahora se
sienten traicionados israel de hecho
acordó suspender sus planes de anexión
de partes de cisjordania como parte del
acuerdo aunque netanyahu ha enfatizado
que estos planes se retrasan pero no se
cancelan además del intercambio de
embajadores y embajadas las relaciones
normales entre emiratos árabes unidos e
israel' también deberían significar
colaboración e inversión turismo
telecomunicaciones y una serie de otras
posibilidades un aspecto clave será la
seguridad en particular hacer frente a
la creciente presencia estratégica de
irán en la región y su programa nuclear
pero israel y emiratos árabes unidos ya
tienen vínculos de seguridad bien
establecidos por lo que esta parte del
acuerdo podría ser poco más que una
formalidad
y el cambio climático está ahora en el
centro de la campaña presidencial de
eeuu y es que durante su visita al
estado de california el presidente de
donald trump desestimó al calentamiento
global como causa de los incendios que
vienen devastando a la costa oeste del
país hace días y que dejan ya al menos
35 víctimas mortales por su parte su
rival demócrata joe biden contraatacó
calificando a trump como un pirómano
climático los detalles en el siguiente
informe
un nuevo actor entra en la carrera a la
casa blanca los incendios en la costa
oeste durante su visita a california a
donde llegó para evaluar la emergencia
provocada por los incendios forestales
el presidente de donald trump se
enfrentó a la comunidad científica por
el cambio climático para empezar a hacer
frío lo van a ver
ojalá la ciencia estuviera de acuerdo
con usted no creo que la ciencia sepa en
realidad
pero hay consenso científico sobre que
el cambio climático está haciendo al
estado de california cada vez más seco y
caliente lo que provoca más incendios
cada década desde 1980 ha sido
sucesivamente más calidad que la década
anterior y es más a los 6 años más
cálidos registrados a núcleo y en los
últimos 6 años desde el 2014 varios
fenómenos extremos no como incendios
forestales olas de calor sequías están
vinculados al aumento de la temperatura
mundial por lo que el demócrata joe
biden aprovechó los comentarios de trump
para atacarlo
si le das a un pirómano climático cuatro
años más en la casa blanca porque
alguien se sorprendería si tienen eeuu
en llamas de desagregación hija del
clima cuatro años más en la casa blanca
porque alguien se sorprendería cuando
más de eeuu esté bajo el agua
necesitamos un presidente que respete
las ciencias que entienda que el daño el
cambio climático ya está aquí a menos
que tomemos medidas urgentes
esto será más catastrófico y es que
mientras el presidente ha derogado
varias regulaciones medioambientales y
retiro a eeuu del acuerdo de parís
maiden anunció un plan de 2 billones de
dólares para incentivar la inversión en
energías renovables y detener las
emisiones contaminantes de las empresas
estadounidenses para el 2035
vamos ahora a españa porque el gobierno
de este país presenta hoy el proyecto de
ley de memoria democrática que busca
ampliar el reconocimiento y también la
reparación a las víctimas del franquismo
entre otras medidas prohíbe cualquier
tipo de reivindicación de la dictadura y
exige además continuar con las
exhumaciones y la identificación de las
víctimas desde madrid' nuestra
corresponsal rosa pérez nos amplía la
información el gobierno presenta hoy el
esperado anteproyecto de ley de memoria
democrática y es que tal y como han
señalado las naciones unidas- es una
anomalía que dados los crímenes que se
produjeron durante el franquismo españa
todavía no haya alcanzado un verdadero
proceso de justicia y reparación y a
falta de conocer la integridad del texto
del anteproyecto de ley sí que hemos
podido conocer ya algunos puntos de esta
nueva legislación por un lado la
pretensión de ilegalizar la fundación
francisco franco y de prohibir en
general las exaltaciones al franquismo
también de profundizar entre los más
jóvenes en el conocimiento de lo que
supuso la represión franquista pero hay
dudas
sobre el rol que asumirá el estado en el
proceso de exhumación de los más de 100
mil desaparecidos que se encuentran en
fosas comunes en todo el país unos
trabajos que hasta ahora asumían
voluntarios de distintas asociaciones
como la de la recuperación de la memoria
histórica una asociación que tomó la
iniciativa en 2010 de llevar los
crímenes del franquismo a argentina
donde se investigan en base a la
jurisdicción universal y que plantean
también otra incógnita y es que qué
eficacia tendrá finalmente la fiscalía
especial que pretende crear el gobierno
para investigar estos crímenes ya que
ahora estos procesos judiciales chocaban
con la ley de amnistía de 1977 una ley
que no se pretende tampoco abolir de hoy
para mañana y finalmente lamentan que no
se pretenda crear una oficina de
atención a las víctimas del franquismo y
de que el texto de esta ley tenga que
ser debatido finalmente en el parlamento
con grupos de extrema derecha como vox
avanzamos con noticias que llegan en el
continente asiático y es que en hong
kong más de 20 activistas prodemocracia
comparecieron ante la corte para
escuchar los cargos en su contra por
haber participado el pasado 4 de junio
en una vigilia que tenía como objetivo
conmemorar a las víctimas de la masacre
de tiananmen quienes asistieron al
evento son acusados de haber incurrido
en reunión ilegal entre los 26
activistas que enfrentan cargos se
encuentra joshua want y el magnate de
los medios y my line
insistimos en condenar la masacre de
tiananmen cada año con una vigilia no es
un crimen insistimos que tenemos el
derecho fundamental de expresarnos en
contra de la masacre de tiananmen y
conmemorar a aquellos que se
sacrificaron y desde la alianza de hong
kong continuaremos esa lucha
y hemos celebrado esta vigilia desde
hace 30 años y continuaremos sin
importar lo que pase incluso con la
imposición de la ley de seguridad
nacional lo haremos de nuevo el próximo
año
avanzamos ahora con otras noticias
destacadas al momento en france 24 en
español las de calidad del caso la vaya
todo el mayor escándalo de corrupción de
la historia de brasil presentó este
lunes una nueva denuncia contra el ex
presidente luiz inácio lula da silva por
el supuesto lavado de dinero
provenientes de sobornos pagados por el
grupo odebrecht cree que el líder
estadounidense ayudante del ex
presidente de nissan motors carlos ghosn
se declaró no culpable de los delitos
por los que es acusado en japón por
presuntas irregularidades financieras
que la justicia atribuye a con acusado
de ocultar a las autoridades
compensaciones pactadas con nissan
y un nuevo incendio sorprende a beirut
la capital libanesa la conflagración en
un reconocido edificio del distrito
comercial este segundo incendio
registrado este mes la capital del
líbano intenta recuperarse todavía del
shock que generó la explosión que
devastó su puerto el pasado 4 de agosto
en otras noticias científicos pueden
haber descubierto evidencia de vida
extraterrestre en uno de los últimos
lugares menos esperados un equipo de
investigadores dice que ha encontrado un
marcador clave de organismos microbianos
en el vecino planeta de venus veamos el
informe
podría la búsqueda de vida
extraterrestre y llevarnos directamente
al vecino de la tierra un equipo
internacional de científicos ha
descubierto un marcador clave de
actividad microbiana en la atmósfera de
venus la fosfina un gas nocivo es común
en planetas gigantes gaseosos como
júpiter pero en planetas rocosos más
pequeños como la tierra y teóricamente
venus la fosfina se produce en la
naturaleza sólo cuando es producida por
pequeños organismos vivos winborg
trabajamos toda la química toda la
química conocida posible que podría
ocurrir en la atmósfera de venus en la
superficie y en el subsuelo y ni un solo
proceso que mirábamos podría producir
fosfina en cantidades suficientes para
explicar los hallazgos de nuestro equipo
sobre la cocina en la atmósfera deben
ser nombrado por la diosa romana de la
belleza y el amor
venus es uno de los objetos más
brillantes visibles en el cielo nocturno
pero sus ópticas de albergar vida
extraterrestre han sido consideradas por
mucho tiempo bastante escasas envuelto
en una espesa y tóxica atmósfera
nubes de ácido sulfúrico las
temperaturas en la superficie del
planeta pueden alcanzar los 470 grados
centígrados pero la atmósfera superior
del planeta podría ser habitable para
los microbios anaeróbicos que no
necesitan oxígeno y a menudo prosperan
en condiciones extremas por lo tanto
muchos científicos siguen siendo
escépticos pero los últimos hallazgos
han intrigado a la comunidad científica
hasta el punto que el actual
administrador de la nasa dijo que ahora
es necesario priorizar a venus
finalizamos otra emisión informativa
quédense con nosotros hay más en france
24 y en france 24 punto com
[Música]